in this lesson we're going to talk about
percentages and percent of change so
this is an important concept you want to
know for the s80 and the new revised s80
so let's go through the concepts so
basically when you find the percent of
change what you do is you take the new
amount minus the old amount divided by
the old amounts you when you find
percent change you want to find out how
it's changing compared to how it was
originally that's why we're dividing by
the old amount when you take the
difference between the new and the old
that's the change but you're comparing
it to or dividing it by the original
amount so that's percent of change you
want to memorize that formula and you
also want to pay attention to the
concept of one hundred percent plus and
one hundred percent minus what I mean by
that is like if something is a markdown
by twenty percent what percent you pay
well that's eighty percent right one
hundred percent minus twenty percent so
you'd want to use point 80 in your
calculations it makes a little bit more
efficient conversely like say something
is increasing by ten percent right then
you're actually going to be paying a
hundred and ten percent which is 1.10 if
you convert it to a decimal so kind of
pay attention to those constants that'll
make some of these percentage problems
lot easier for you let's get into some
examples go ahead and pause the video
like normal and you know duties that's
will get the most benefit from these
problems so the first one says if a
sweater last month was forty-eight
dollars and fifty cents right and this
month is fifty-six dollars and
seventy-five cents by what percent did
the sweater increase okay so this one
you know pretty much an easy problem
right so all you'd have to do is take
the new amount 5675 mine it's the old
amount 4850 but we want to make sure
we're dividing it by forty 8.50 the
original amount because we want to see
how it's changing compared to what it
was right so 56.7 5-40 8.5 divided at by
48.5 we're getting about us having teen
percent increase which comes out 20
point 17 but you want to move that
decimal two places to the right okay so
that was pretty easy let's go to example
number to see if you can do this one on
your own make sure you pause the video
and attempt it on your own so write an
expression for the total cost of a
computer that is marked X dollars
originally okay X dollars originally
after a twenty-five percent discount
followed by a six percent sales tax so
how would you do that problem well let's
take a look so basically you're starting
with X dollars it's a discount of 25% so
that means you're actually only paying
75 percent of the original price right
then you're taking this whole quantity
in you're paying sales tax of six
percent that's a six percent increase so
that's really like a hundred and six
percent where if you convert 106 percent
to a decimal that's 1.06 so if you look
down the answers here it looks like the
best answer is letter B it's the
original price x 75 percent times a 1
point 06 so that's the best way to do
these promises again think about one
hundred percent plus one hundred percent
minus depending up it's an increase your
decrease and then also memorize this
percent of change formula that will help
as well and we do this lesson if you
need to otherwise they'll see you in the
next lesson